Joseph starts this hour in Providence
Rhode Island
hi Joseph how are you how are you better
than I deserve what's up I just wanted
to call you today to get some advice
from you I'm having some issues with my
girlfriend I'm trying to get her to do
the Deaf snowball with me and she's got
like five credit cards and some student
loans her cars are paid off she's got
her own house she's got about 150,000
left on her mortgage and I'm just really
trying to talk with her and get her on
the bandwagon with that and she's got
some problems with anxiety and
depression and stuff and talking about
that according to her
supposedly triggered that and it's just
been very difficult mm-hmm is she in
counseling for her anxiety and her
depression she was at a time and she
stopped for a few months okay if you
have anxiety and depression of the part
that to the point that you cannot live
your life well you need help with that
and you don't get you don't get to stop
you get help and I know you get healed
and you need some healing and because
when you say you can't talk about money
what you're saying is I can't talk about
life because money flows to every part
of your life right and so it might be
that that's a load of crap it might be
that she's just doesn't want to talk
about money because she doesn't want
anybody telling her what to do
that might beggar this I kind of I kind
of got that vibe Dave um you know her
parents
that's definitely boiled there no is not
a word she wants to hear nor is it a
word she wants to tell her herself she
won't tell herself no and certainly a
new with her anxiety her and her
depressions can't do it she being a bit
spoiled brat I could be I don't know I'm
just guessing it could be it could be
both but anyway so here's the deal
there are four things that marriage
research
tells us you must be an agreement on if
you want a high probability of a
successful marriage the number one cause
of divorce in North America today and
trouble in marriage is money fights
number one okay and so you know anytime
you find the number one cause of
something you deal with that if you're
gonna be doing that something so if this
relationships gonna get serious and move
towards marriage this has to be dealt
with is what I'm saying you guys have to
have some discussions you have to get on
the same page you have to have an agreed
value system to go forward because if
you marry a princess you're gonna have
what's known as a long freaking life
okay right so you don't want to do that
and if she marries a jerk that doesn't
want to work much and doesn't want to
pay his bills she's going to have a long
life right and so you guys need to be in
alignment about how you're going to
handle money and what our view of money
savings and debt and investing and
generosity is and we need to have some
alignment on those things now she
doesn't have to be exactly like you but
you need to have had these discussions
and be in alignment on those the other
three think three things by the way on
the in the statistical data on marriage
or being in agreement on in-laws kids
and religion like kids if we're going to
have them how many and how they're going
to be treated are the inmates going to
run the asylum how we gonna deal with
boundary issues an extended family which
is crazy in laws and so forth
interfering people all that kind of junk
and then you know religion and
Christians call that unequally yoked so
anyway if you're an agreement on those
four things and you've had some good
pre-marriage counseling and good healthy
non toxic discussions where we're
aligned on those four things
statistically you have a very high
probability of your marriage winning so
that's how I would talk to her about it
I'll just go listen this is a big deal
because it's the ingredients it's one of
the big ingredients for success
and I want a relationship to be
successful so for your relationship to
take the next step and become more
serious towards marriage this has to be
dealt with and you gently and kindly and
but you need to figure it out ahead of
time don't and don't think we get
married well straighten it out then oh
[Music]
okay this is something to deal with
before the engagement ring goes on the
finger yes I method in the butt fast as
I can
well I mean it's a deal-breaker right
right and it's not because money is that
big a deal it's because your value
system how you spend money says what's
important to you how you handle money
and if you're gonna put your hands over
your ears and go lalala lalala and act
like we don't have to deal with this and
somebody's gonna swoop in the fairy
godmothers gonna take care of us the
government's gonna help us retire which
is well known for its ability to handle
money you're gonna be broke your whole
life I mean I could spend on these
credit cards there's no end in sight
you're not in Congress you got to have a
plan so that's the thing so you got you
know if we're going to practice denial
because it causes a stress denials a
river in Egypt we can't do this it's an
it doesn't work ma'am that's that's what
you guys got and so you can have some
kind gentle discussions and probe but
only to the extent the relationship is
moving forward and the relationship is
stalled until you get past this hurdle
at some point now again if you've been
on three dates it's not something you
talk about that much that would be weird
but unless you've met on the in the Dave
Ramsey community or something on
Facebook but which we've now had three
engagements on there but but if you're
not if you didn't meet there then it's
weird to talk about this on the first
two or three dates it's you know there's
a lot of stuff you don't it's a very
intimate subject it's not something you
do in casual conversation the first
go-round or two so anyway that that's
it's a big deal though folks for you to
be aligned and those of you out there
that are married I mean get you and your
spouse being on the same team is just
it's just all the data points are there
it's almost impossible to drag someone
down the road to wealth you kicking and
screaming against their will
it's almost impossible to do that it's
almost impossible to out-earn someone's
spending addiction it's almost
impossible to out-earn your stupidity
and lack of organization I tried it I
couldn't do it
I'm pretty good at making money but I
couldn't make enough money to get past
my stupid because I do stupid big when I
do it and so you cannot do that you've
got to be aligned you've got to be on
the same team you have to make decisions
together that are major decisions and be
unified about it and you know Sharon and
I practice that to this day it is the
recipe to a great marriage of increases
communication quality communication
it increases intimacy it increases the
probability of your building wealth
working together
you are not roommates once you put the
finger the end the ring and you say I do